create a more sex positive culture
sex negative yeah how would you do that
Auntie just jumped out of it didn't they
have them in America somewhere where
they have those um
is it celibacy
when they go into schools and stuff
that's what I grew up getting that's
true that's it that's supposed to be
speakers that's what they should do and
we had no everyone's set okay
I had a certain I'm not gonna name
certain some would say oh the Catholic
schools were so bad looking I don't know
what Catholic schools you all went to we
had no teen pregnancies in my high
school and we did chat that's what they
always say oh if you don't understand
you guys are gonna go crazy
no we're much better than the public
schools I mean there were no Catholic
schools
the girls that plenty of sex didn't get
pregnant because they use contraception
but it was nice
the company